Kako sad to radi i da ti kaže kako bi trebalo, ja ću ti ispisati, u stvari upali ste imanje naravno
Ipario sam, za svakšen slučaj
Pokušat ću da ispišem što bolje
Ovo je sad, vidiš, ne znam, prijemno...
Da, vidim, vidim, sad je okej
Dobra, sad ovde imamo blablabla
Sad vidi, ove vrednosti što se unose ovde, one su kako da kažem konačne i najjedine tačne vrednosti. Ono što se unose u prijemnici su neke projekcije što ne znamo koliko će biti tačan kurs dolara, pa ima neke dotnih troškova, ovi na carini mogu da nam prihvate cene pa da lupe veću carinu, neke stavi i manju, ima svega i svačega.
ali uglavnom ono što se upiš ovde u prijemnici
to su cifre koje su za knjigovodstvo
razumeš, to je jedino tačno
to je jedna stvar
druga stvar, vidim sad da ovde si stavio raspod
da locik freze prema vrednosti robe
da li može sve da ide prema zapremini?
može
sve da ide prema zapremini i ako slučajno nema neka zapremina
onda ga blokiraj
Ali smo već stavili da je kod artikala obavezno da se unese ili pun kontejnjer ili ove kakve
I prioritet i ono pun kontejnjer
Tako da, onda sad kad dođeš ovde dole imaš, ali sad si to ukinuo, e da ovo koks korekcija
Ne znam šta ti je to koks korekcija, to ti je vratna korekcija u odnosu na nabavnu poručbenicu
Čekaj da vidim samo sekund.
A to je razlika između ovog procenjenog troška i stvarnog troška?
Epa to.
Možemo da promenimo.
Možemo da promenimo, ako hoćeš.
To i da vidim koliko smo omašili,
jer to u projekcijama treba da budu što manje greške.
Ti pa 13 hiljina, da to je uparkli toko greške.
Nego je bitno samo ovde dole,
da se računa koliko spor tiku,
da se, kako se zove, računa,
da nema ti korekcije,
nego se uzimaju ove cifre ovde,
koje su unete u uzlavlju prijemnice
jasno
nemaš da umeš
jasno, jasno, jasno
kažem ti, ovo kokos reakcija mi je super da imam kao informaciju
ali ovo da dole
da nema nikak
tako je, da
dobro, važi, važi
nije, nije, nije, nije reda
ne, sad, samo tu vrednost, robe
znaš šta bi tu trebalo
se začunao sad
kako sam ja računao kad sam imao to u Excelu
ti sad imaš
ove šifre, imaš nabavnu cenu, imaš ukupnu vrednost robe.
Ti treba tu ukupnu vrednost robe da prema nabavnjima, da se račumaš u stvari srednji kulus dolara.
Znaš šta sam ja račuma? Na primjer, vrednost fakture, URSA-D.
Je ovo, osamljena, da staviš koliko je vrednost fakture ispod u dolarima i koji je srednji kulus dolara.
i onda nosi u tog srednjeg kursa dolara
da množiš nabavnu cenu za tu
poručbenicu pa da dobiš
jednu srobe. Ne znam kako sad radiš
možda radiš i tako ali
Evo, da se prati kada ću se da proverim i to
jer to sam radio
kazem ti
pre neki dana
Tome to.
Eur, ja sam tu, euročni misa.